[Musik]
mitten im leverkusener stadtteil opladen
steht dieses schicke buswartehäuschen
die nordrhein westfälische stadt hat es
dort aufgestellt damit sich bei wind und
wetter fahrgäste unterstellen können
aber der standort hat einen ganz
entscheidenden nachteil
die busse fahren am wartehäuschen vorbei
und halten erst 30 meter weiter in
opladen ist die aufregung groß
also ich finde das unverschämt 100 ist
für mich ein aprilscherz die leute die
sofort planen die müssen eine abmahnung
kriegen blödsinnig ich hab mich schon
gewundert dass aufgebaut worden ist das
überhaupt dahin gebaut worden ist wenn
der kein bus hält es ist ja nicht
irgendwie ganz plötzlich aus einer
bushaltestelle ist na ja die war schon
immer da und das wartehäuschen ist am
etliche meter weiter entfernt was aus
meiner sicht keinen sinn ergibt im
spätsommer vergangenen jahres baut die
stadt das wartehäuschen dorthin wo der
bus tatsächlich hält doch dann beginnt
die geschichte aus pleiten pech und
pannen
denn beim aufbau wird erstmal ein
wichtiges stromkabel beschädigt danach
stellt man fest dass der unterstand die
freie sicht auf die denkmalgeschützten
häuser dahinter stört aber gestört wird
hier wohl nur der freie blick auf werbe-
und leuchtreklame trotzdem muss das
häuschen wieder weg es wandert 30 meter
weiter während der bus haltepunkt bleibt
wo er ist
wer hier jetzt auf den bus wartet muss
sehr gut zu fuß sein um ihn auch zu
erwischen gerade für ältere menschen
eine echte zumutung es ist sinnlos für
mich und ich bin der meinung man sollte
man sich in rollator nehmen und sich in
dieses wetterhäuschen reinstellen und
versuchen auch wenn man gesunder mensch
ist dann diesen bus drüben zu bekommen
im leverkusener rathaus will sich
niemand vor der kamera äußern
den ärger der bürger kann man aber
nachvollziehen allerdings kommt einzig
dieser standort in frage
aufgrund der räumlichen stark
eingeschränkten gegebenheiten müsste
alternativ auf die aufstellung eines
wartehäuschens verzichtet werden
laut stadt haben die wartehäuschen
wandertage bislang sie
1300 euro gekostet für die betroffenen
bürger ein schlechter scherz
das ist einfach geldverschwendung das
ist einfach sinnlose es ist blödsinn
aber warum kann der bus nicht hier
halten war muss der bus da halten dann
kann man das nicht um ändern
gute frage denn mittlerweile prüft auch
die stadt ob das wartehäuschen nicht
doch da stehen kann wo es tatsächlich
hingehört an die bushaltestelle